>> GO, GO, GO, TOUCHDOWN!
>> IS EVERYONE ENJOYING THE BIG
GAME?
>> COME ON BABE, DON'T ACT LIKE
YOU KNOW SPORTS.
>> MY HUSBAND'S RIGHT.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE BIG GAME,
THERE'S ONLY ONE THING I KNOW
ABOUT.
FEEDING MY HUNGRY GUYS.
>> NO!
OH, FUMBLE!
>> AND THIS YEAR'S GAME IS
BIGGER THAN EVER.
WHICH MEANS I'LL BE FEEDING THEM
MORE TOTINOS THAN EVER.
>> BABE, NEED MORE TOTINOS, DAVE
JUST GOT HERE.
>> NOT A PROBLEM.
BECAUSE THIS YEAR I'VE GOT THE
NEW TOTINO TOTINO TWO-PACK.
IT'S TWICE THE TOTINO FOR TWICE
THE HUNGRY GUYS.
>> ENOUGH YAPPING, WE NEED THE
TOTINOS.
TED'S HERE TOO, AND HE BROUGHT
HIS SISTER.
>> GREAT, MORE HANDS TO HELP ME
MAKE DELICIOUS TOTINOS --
♪♪♪
>> PIZZA ROLLS.
OH, MY.
>> HI.
I'M SABINE.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
>> I'VE NEVER HAD ONE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT'S A SHAME.
♪♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I SHOULD BRING THESE OUT.
>> NO, STAY WITH ME.
>> WHAT ABOUT MY HUNGRY GUYS?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WHAT ARE YOU HUNGRY FOR?
>> TOUCHDOWN!
YES!
>> HEY, BABE, WE NEED THOSE
TOTINOS, WHAT'S GOING ON BACK
THERE?
♪♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WHAT IS IT?
>> EVERY BIG GAME BEFORE THIS
ONE, I'VE BEEN ASLEEP.
BUT, SABINE --
[ SPEAKING FRENCH ]
>> THEY'RE GOING TO PUNT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪♪♪
[ SPEAKING FRENCH ]
>> BABE, WHAT'S TAKING SO LONG
WITH THOSE TOTINOS?
YOU GIRLS MAKING OUT BACK THERE?
>> HA HA HA!
>> YOU'RE CRAZY.
♪♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> TOTINO.
THIS SPRING, FIND YOUR TOTINO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> BABE?